from 1990 to 1991 TV viewers were
obsessed with a tantalizing question who
killed Laura Palmer that was the central
mystery on Twin Peaks a stylish bizarre
murder mystery set in the Pacific
Northwest
now that the show's long-awaited third
season has returned 26 years later let's
step into the Red Room or a cup of
gamifying coffee and have a look into
the seedy underbelly of Twin Peaks
inspired by Marilyn Monroe in the late
80s Warner Brothers asked David Lentz to
direct a biopic based on goddess a 1985
biography of Marilyn Monroe Lynch teamed
up with mark frost to write the
screenplay but the studio pulled out for
what Lynch called political reasons
specifically Ian Frost believed the
conspiracy theory that Monroe was
murdered because of her relationship
with the Kennedys Lynch and frost so
liked working together that they began
collaborating on a TV series that would
become Twin Peaks the idea that Monroe's
death was not quite what it seemed
factored into what ultimately became
more of Parma's faith on Twin Peaks
still David Lynch wouldn't let the whole
Monroe thing go
what really went on between Marilyn
Monroe and the Kennedys and who really
pulled the trigger on JFK population
whatever in the opening credits of Twin
Peaks the fictional town is said to have
a population of 50 1201 creatives Lynch
and Frost wanted the town to be even
smaller with a population of 5,000 120
but ABC thought that people wouldn't you
noon to a show about a tiny rural town
the producers made them add an extra
digit and multiply the population
tenfold even though the area cats it's
very small-town vibe later Lynch and
frost got around ABC's order to change
the population in the 1991 tie-in book
Twin Peaks access guide to the town they
wrote the Twin Peaks recently discovered
our population is not 50 1201 the 1990
census revealed our present population
is 5100
2.1 not 50 1201
that point one person wasn't officially
revealed but we all know it's probably
the baby from Eraserhead
the origin of bob spoilers the guy
behind Twin Peaks murders was Bob an
evil monster that possesses people and
makes them do horrible things
except when Twin Peaks was originally
scripted Bob wasn't even a character in
fact David Lynch never even wanted to
reveal who killed Laura Palmer at all of
course a murder that goes unsolved for
years didn't fit well with ABC
executives who urged Lynch and Frost to
identify the murderer at the end of the
first season which they didn't do they
even went one further and slapped
another potential murder or two on top
the writers even sent the network
a fake finale script to indicate that
they were playing along the unsolved
murder of Maura Palmer along with the
show's huge ratings ensured a season two
renewal and even more pressure from ABC
to say who killed her enter Frank Silva
the twin peaks' set dresser while
shooting a scene for the pilot Silva was
putting finishing touches on a room when
Lynch realized that if he were to shoot
the scene at that moment
Silva would appear in the frame Silva
recalled in the 1993 interview and
suddenly he said wait a minute Frank get
down to the base of the bed crouch down
look through those wrought iron bars and
act scared and it just sort of
snowballed from there later in a
completely fortunate accident
Silva can be spotted in a mirror during
the pilot cementing his place in the
series and essentially revealing the
series murderer in the pilot episode you
know if you had a DVR back in 1991
Cooper and Horne the first season of the
show featured a budding bromance between
visiting investigator Agent Dale Cooper
played by Kyle MacLachlan and Audrey
Horne played by sherilyn fenn but then
the plot thread was abruptly dropped
reportedly McLaughlin asked Lynch to
break them up because he didn't think a
straight-laced
older guy like Cooper would date a
high-school student but then told the
a/v Club that the real reason was onset
mentioned at the time McLaughlin was
dating cast member Lara Flynn Boyle and
she and fen did not get along
Boyle apparently resented the screen
time that fan was getting as the
romantic interest of the show's main
character in order to keep the peace
hearts had to be broken the truth of mr.
Tamura in the first season finale of
Twin Peaks Leo acting at the behest of
Ben Horne sets fire to Kathryn Martel's
Packard sawmill and Kathryn played by
Piper Laurie is believed to have died in
the place in truth Kathryn survives but
under the guise of a Japanese
businessman named mr. Toto Moreau the
writers didn't want anyone including the
cast and crew to know what was going on
so Piper Laurie's name was taken out of
the credits but she still showed up on
set each day completely ready to play
mr. Tamura wearing a suit in several
layers of prosthetics and makeup as
Laurie relates in her memoir learning to
live out loud cast and crew were told
that this person was a legendary
Japanese actor named Fumio Yamaguchi and
that he didn't speak English cast member
Peggy Lipton still thought something was
up and assumed that the Japanese actor
wandering silently around the set was
actually a disguised Isabella Rossellini
who had dated David Lynch around the
time Twin Peaks was in production and is
no stranger to weird costumes the lobe
lady one of the quirkiest characters on
Twin Peaks was the log lady portrayed by
Catherine Colson surprisingly David
Lynch came up with the log lady in the
late 70s years before he co-created Twin
Peaks while on the set of his cult
classic Eraserhead
where Colson was an assistant director
seeing cool scene in the glasses during
a late-night shoot and with would
apparently on his mind Lynch told
Coulson's that he wanted to make the TV
series starring her Sunday called I'll
test my log with every branch of
knowledge according to Lynch the idea
was that Kathryn would go with the log
to various experts a dentist a doctor a
physicist and they would talk only to
the log and we would learn that
information as importance while that
never happens the log lady was brought
to life in a slightly different form for
Twin Peaks
Audrey Horne spin-off after the show had
been on the air for a while sherilyn
fenn Audrey Horne emerged as a fan
favorite so Lynch and frost proposed a
Twin Peaks spin-off feature film to fend
centered around her character moving to
California according to them they talked
about an opening scene of their driving
along Mulholland Drive and how she's a
little bit older whatever it was going
to be it never ended up happening to me
it didn't happen for her but the idea of
a young woman getting into bizarre
adventures in Southern California is
pretty much the plot of Lynch's 2001
movie Mulholland Drive which is no
coincidence other revivals the last
episode of the original run of Twin
Peaks features some kind of spectral
Laura Palmer telling agent Cooper that
you'll see him again in 25 years now 26
years later and after some production
delays the show has returned but that's
not a long time to wait in the grand
scheme of botched Twin Peaks
continuation attempts in 1993 cable
network Bravo
secured the rights to air reruns of the
show and persuaded David Lynch to write
and direct new introductions to the
episodes as a potential part of a deluxe
DVD release of the full series in 2007
Twin Peaks story editor Bob angles
teamed up with comic artist Matt Haley
to create a canonical third season of
the show in graphic novel format based
on the original notes for the show's
canceled third season among the plot
points Dale Cooper moves to Twin Peaks
to work as the town pharmacist and Bob
may or may not have been from a planet
made of creamed corn
the graphic novel was ultimately never
finished because David Lynch refused to
sign off on it and after hearing about
Planet corn maybe that's for the best
thanks for watching click the liver icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
you get all this cool stuff we know you
love to
[Music]